[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم جرت العاده في مسيره المستشرقين
الحديث منهم على وجه التحديد ان جل
النشاطه وفكره وعمله يفضي الى قراءه خاصه
لواقع الاسلام والمسلمين والعرب تحديدا
تميل او تخدموا او في اضعف الاحوال لا
تتميز مع الرؤيه الاستعماريه التي خلفتها
اوروبا عن عالمنا لكن هذا الامر لم يحدث
مع المفكر الفرنسي فرانسوا برجا الرجل
الذي خبر الاسلام السياسي بشكل معمق عبر
كتبه الاربعه الشهيره الاسلام السياسي صوت
الجنوب عن الحركه الاسلاميه في بلدان
المغرب العربي كتاب وجها لوجه مع الاسلام
السياسي ثم كتاب الاسلام السياسي في زمن
القاعده عام 2005 واخيرا كتاب فهم الاسلام
السياسي شكل رؤيه نراها نحن اكثر دقه
وانصافا عن العلاقه الملتبسه بين المسلمين
واوروبا وهو اليوم يدفع ثمن هذه القراءه
المنصفه والموضوعيه في بلاده فرنسا لان
نمو تيار اليم متطرف لم يدع مجالا للمهنيه
والموضوعيه والامانه العلميه واليمين الذي
كان تيارا سياسيا وشعبويا في فرنسا اصبح
هو الدوله كما يرى بورجا ويلخصها بعبارته
الشهيره المسلم الطيب في فرنسا هو المسلم
الذي يتخلى عن اسلامه لم يعد ثمه تباين
بين يسار او يمين الكل في العنصريه وعداء
الاخر سواء استضيف الرجل الليله للحديث عن
هذه العلاقه المضطربه وما يجري في فرنسا
ثم اوروبا والى اين تتجه والرؤى المتطرفه
التي بدات تحكم الدوله الفرنسيه كما يرى
احد باحثيها المطلوق مشاهدينا الكرام
البروفيسور
في المقابل هذا المساء فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في حلقه
جديده من المقابله استضيف فيها المثقف
والاكاديميه الفرنسيه
الباحث الذي قضى جانبا طويلا من حياته في
العالم العربي الباحث الفرنسيه والذي يعني
تعمق حقيقه في الحاله العربيه والاسلاميه
بشكل عام مرحبا بك يا بروفيسور سعداء
بوجودك في المقابله للمره الثانيه بعد
ثمانيه اعوام
مرحبا اهلا بكم جزيلا لهذه الدعوه الحقيقه
نلتقي اليوم والظروف تتغير عما كنا عليه
قبل ثمانيه اعوام الحاله الاشكاليه
المتعلقه بالعلاقه بين اوروبا والاسلام
بشكل عام اوروبا والعالم العربي بشكل خاص
اوروبا والمسلمين في في داخلها ايضا بشكل
اكثر خصوصيه تزداد تعقيدا وتكثر
الاشكاليات حولها ماكرون لديه تصريح شهير
حينما قال الاسلام يبدو ان الاسلام في
ازمه وبعيدا عن تصريحه كسياسي وكرايس وفي
السياقات الفرنسيه الداخليه الا انه يشير
الى امر مهم جدا يتعلق بوجود ازمه كبرى في
العلاقه الاوروبيه بالاسلام والمسلمين
انت خير من يتحدث في هذا الامر خير من
يفهم
كيف ترى اوروبا واقع الاسلام والمسلمين
والعالم العربي ما هي طبيعه هذه الازمه في
العلاقه برايك بروفيسور من جديد استاذه
علي اسمحوا لي اشكركم لهذه الدعوه لهذه
الفرصه لتبادل الاراء معك ومع المشاهدين
الكرام في الحقيقه
ازمه العلاقات
وعزمه هذا
العنصريه ضد المسلمين ليست قد هي اوروبيه
فقط اذا ننظر الى السين مثلا الى منظور
الى الهند حاليا
ولكن فيما يخص اوروبا اسمحوا لي ربما ان
اركز على النموذج الفرنسي لماذا لان كلنا
موافقيننا الوضع الفرنسي حاليا اسوا
من اي بلد في اوروبا وما يتعلق بالعلاقه
مع المسلمين علاقات
في اوروبا او احيانا العلاقات الدوليه لكن
علاقات
الانظمه والمجتمعات ربما الاوروبيه
مع المسلمين ربما نسفها نسف النموذج لما
نركز على في فرنسا
والسبب الثاني ان قد تكون
الوضع الحالي في فرنسا مستقبل الوضع في
الدول المجاوره
ينقسم التحليل اعتقد الى جانبين جانب
تاريخي لماذا انتقلت المجتمعات الاوروبيه
الى هذا النوع من التوتر مع المسلمين جانب
تاريخي وجانب حالي والجانب حالي نتخلص منه
ونقول ان تتم في فرنسا خاصه منذ سنه
2019 تنافس
بين القوى السياسيه في موضوع وحيد وهو
التعامل مع المسلمين
اشرح لك في الماضي في الماضي الخطاب
الاسلاموفوبي كان محدود الى فئات معينه من
المجتمع الفرنسي اليمين المتشدد
المتطرف اليمين ثم انتقل الى اجزاء من
اليسار غيرنا ابتداء من سنه 2019 هذا
الخطاب العنصري اصبح خطاب الدوله اصبح
خطاب الدوله يعني كان في سياق التنافس
السياسي تطورا من اليمين المتطرف الى
اليمين الى معسكره اليسار حتى اصبح خطاب
دوله
احيانا
استعمل
جمله استفزازيه شويه ان اقول ان الصراع
السياسيه الحقيقيه حاليا في فرنسا ليس مثل
ما كان في الماضي بين اليسار واليمين
الصراع السياسي التنافس السياسي الحقيقي
بين يمين المتشدد في الحكومه ويمين
المتشددين في المعارضه بين يمينين
بين يمينين
[موسيقى]
والسبب ان مكروه في بعض
سنتين في السلطه بعد ازمه
السترات الصفراء اعتقد
فهم ان لا يستطيع استقطاب اصوات
الناخبين الوسطيه واليساريه لا بد من
استقطاب اصوات اليمين المتشدد ماذا تعني
حينما تقول انه هذا الخطاب المتطرف خطاب
اصبح خطاب الدوله الفرنسيه انا اعطيك مثل
في الماضي الدوله الفرنسيه كانت يجرم يقمع
يدين
ليس لاقليه المسلمين بل لاكثريه مواطني
المسلمين ابتداء من
2020 بدا الحكومه الفرنسيه
تمنع
الممارسه العاديه لتقوس الدين الاسلامي
والضريع كان ان
الانتماء الديني
اخلته بداوا يخلطون بعض الانتماء الديني
العادي والانفاليه
الانفصاليه بمعنى نرفض مبادئ
المشتركه
للجمهوريه الفرنسيه
والانفاليه كانت مدخل
للارهاب في توجد خطاب جديد ليس في حامش
المجتمع الفرنسي بيع في قمه الحكومه وخاصه
في الوزير الداخليه ضخمنه ان يغلط بين
الذي
يحترم
مثلا
الاكل الحلال او يسلي مرتين كل يوم او
طموحات معينه للتربيه اطفاله
يغلط هذا هذه الممارسات جو الدين الاسلامي
بجو الرفط مبادئ الجمهوريه وهو مدخل الى
الارهاب انا اريد ان اركز على الجانب
التاريخي المسار الثاني الذي ذكرت انه في
مسارين في المساله لكن قبلها لديك عباره
شهيره بروفيسور تقول المسلم الطيب في نظر
ماكرون والمتشددين هو المسلم الذي يتخلى
عن اسلامه
الخطاب المتشد خطاب الاسلام وفوبيا كان
خطابا يمينيا متشددا ثم اصبح خطابا يمينيا
ثم يساريا الى درجه كبيره ثم اصبح خطاب
الدوله حينما يقول ماكرون ليس كما كان
يجري في السابق التشدد الارهاب الاسلامي
الارهابيين اصبح الاسلام في ازمه يبدو ان
المساله اصبحت متعلقه بالدين كهويه
كممارسه كنتماء بشكل عام لم تعد مساله
مرتبطه بشيء لا يعجبنا في الاسلام اصبحت
باسلام كامل لا يعجبنه
هل هذا الدقيق ولا لا فيها مبالغه شويه لا
لا ما في مبالغه
اولا مبدئيا لما نركز على الانتماء الديني
لمؤات معين يعني ان ننفي نتجاهل الابعاد
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه الامام مهم للغايه
كل ما نقول باللغه الفرنسيه
جوهريه لما اشرح كل ما تفعل
كانك مسلم اخطر في دوافع اخرى في دوافع
اجتماعيه في دوافع سياسيه
والتجاهل
الجو السياسي في ممارسات المواطنين
الفرنسيين اذا خطا منهاجها لكن بصفه اخرى
السيف مع حدث في الخطاب الحكومي وفي خطاب
وسائل الاعلام الكبرى في فرنسا في الماضي
كنا نجرب
الجهاديين طرف الجهاديين كلمه فرنسيه اكثر
من ما هو عربيه الجهاد العربي يعني قد
تكون
وقد تكون لها معنى نبيله لكن كنا نركز على
الجهاديين العمل المسلح ثم بدات اثناء
نجرم السلفيين او ساعه في من السلفيين
الذين يرفضون العمل السياسي ويرفضون الى
العمل العسكري اندمت السلفيين ثم انتقلنا
الى اخواننا وحادثه
نشات حمله
حكوميه
رسميه على صوت ريس وزير الداخلي ضد تيار
اخواني المسلمين
شيئا فشيئا تقوم الختاب السائد في اوروبا
الى توسيع
عدد المسلمين الذين من حق الحكومه ان
تجرمهم واستهداف كان بالاول لمن يستخدم
العنف ثم تطور الاخوان ثم عموم المسلمين
وتوجد كلمه جديده في
باللغه الفرنسيه
كلمه جديده
نقول البيئه البيئه والجو كنا في الماضي
نجرم فلانه شيء فشيء بدات نقول نجرب فلان
وجيرانهم اقريبهم اخيهم لماذا لانهم تنتمي
الى بيئه
فلان
هي البيئه الاسلاميه
والمشكل والمشكل
اللباس مرتين والصلاه تمشي مرتين في في
مطعم حلال
تعتبر ان انت في بيئه في بيئه الانتماء
الديني المتشدد فهذا خطير جدا خليني اسال
ايضا حتى نكون يعني قليله من التوازن انه
كانه الصراع بين دوله في فرنسا او في
اوروبا بشكل عام تريد مسلمين بلا اسلام
تماما وايضا مع مع مسلمين يريدون ان
يتحولوا لاوروبيين ولكنهم دون ان يتغيروا
ابدا هذا جانب اخر ايضا من الاشكاليه ولا
لا
تجد طبعا
سلوكيات الضيف
وانا انا اجنبي اذا تستقبلني
وانت تحترمني
ما احاول ان افرد اسلوب
عنيف معارض خاص مختلف من الجوف في المجتمع
اذا ارفد اذا ارفد منك اي من اثار انتمائك
الماضي اجعل رد فعله وهذا ما يحدث في
فرنسا حاليا
يعني هل يجب تعريف المسلمين كضيوف في
فرنسا واوروبا
كانوا
عود الى ما انظر اليك كانه لب توترات
حاليا في فرنسا
ذكرت الخلفيه التاريخيه اوكي الخلفيه
التاريخيه للصعوبات العلاقات بين
المسلمين وفرنسا تنقسم الى ثلاث ابعاد
البعد الاول تنافس بين الاديان
فرنسا تنظر اليه كانه مجتمع مسيحي وتنظر
الى الاسلام دين اجنبي غير انا ما اعتقد
ان هذا الدافع العادي الطبيعي هو الدافع
الرئيسي لماذا لان اولا فرنسا ليس بلد
مسيحي
هو لائكي علماني متطرف من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
اخرى يبدو اكثر مسيحيه حتى من المسيح
الاعتيادي والطبيعي يعني فرنسا يعني
اغلبيه
فليس هناك
بالاضافه الى ذلك تجدنا اقليه الناس
المتدينين المسيحيين ليسوا اشد
الفاعلين السياسيين ضد المسلمين عندهم
عندهم قيم مشتركه الى اعداد من القضايا
اجتماعيه مشتركه بين المسلمين فننتقل الى
الدافع الثاني الدافعه او هذا الاول
في فرنسا اللايكيه الفرنسيه العلمانيه
المتجدده الفرنسيه التي جاءت من ظروف
الثوره الفرنسيه في سنه 1789
وجدوا انفسهم الثوار الفرنسيون امام
الكنيسه التي كانت
وسيله بيد السلطه المطلقه للملك تحلى
تحلفوا
الكنيسه
والمؤسسه الدينيه مرتبطه بالاستبداد
وانشات اللائكيه العنيفه لذا لذا حاولوا
الفرنسيون
ان يتخلصوا ان
تنافس الاديان الخصوصيه اللائكيه الفرنسيه
مثل مثل
هذه الخصوصيه الفرنسيه تشرح لنا لماذا
البريطانيون لما يلتقي مع
النساء ترتدي الحجاب تقبل ما عنده مشكله
ما عندهم مع الهنود مع كل شيء مع
الامريكان يكتبون على اوراق المال
نؤمن بالله
نحن ليس من الممكن طردنا الدين خارج
الحقل خارج الفضائل وبالتالي عداء
المسلمين ضمن السياق ولكن ما انظر
كان هما لب الموضوع لب الموضوع ليس صراع
بين الاديان ليس صرا بين الوجود الديني
والعلمانيه
الصراع الحقيقي في فرنسا حاليا ان جاء من
ان احفظ
المستعمرين يرفضون وجود احفاد المستعمرين
يرفضون الناس احفاد المستعمرين يرفعون
صوتهم في في المجتمع الفرنسي يطلبون به
حقوقهم يطلبون اكثر من حقوقهم مرتبطه
لجنسيه للمواطنهم يطلبون بحق كتابه صفحه
التاريخ اندماجهم الى الوطن الفرنسي
بروفيسور انت دائما يعني صاحب منشات
المسلم الطيب هو الذي يتخلى عنه الان هذه
العباره في غايه احفاد المستعمرين
يتنافسون ويتصارعون مع احفاد المستعمرين
في فرنسا
اعتقد صدقني خصوصيه لوب الموضوع ليس ان
المسلم يا دين دين اخر ليس ان المسلم يدين
دين بينما بقيت المجتمع تركت وتفتكر ان
ترك الدين اللب الموضوع ان المسلم هو من
احفاد من الجيل الرابع اسمح لي اقول لك
لماذا الان وليس في بعض الحرب العالميه
الثانيه الجيل الاول من المستعمرين من
المستعمرين
المسلمين الذين جاؤوا من شمال افريقيا
خاصه مسكين ما كانوا يتكلم اللغه الفرنسيه
الجيل الثاني ما كانوا يكتبون الجيل
الثالث ما كانوا يجيدون
اساليب التواصل والاعلام الجلل الربيع
وخامس حاليا عندهم الخبره عندهم القدره
الثقه في انفسهم ويرفعون اصواتهم داخل
المجتمع ماذا يريد الجيل ماذا يريد احفاد
المستعمرين الفرنسيون المسلمون الان ماذا
يريدون بالضبط
اشياء بسيطه جدا مثلا
اعتراف
بحقوقهم
تعرف ان اذا اسمك محمد تبحث العمل في
فرنسا
تذيع خمسه او سته مرات
الوقت الذي يحتاج او بغناغ لايجاد عمل هذا
من
المطالبه قد تكون دينيه لكن
حقوق الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
عقب اندلاع الاحتجاجات التي عرفت بالسترات
الصفراء في فرنسا اعلن الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون بدا ما سماه النقاش الكبير
خاضت غالبيه النخب والقوى والتيارات
السياسيه في البلاد نقاشا مفتوحا كشف حده
الاستقطاب السياسي والفجوات الناجمه عن
التفاوت الطبقي والاقتصادي والاجتماعي
وبعد جولات من النقاشات الساخنه خرج
ماكرون ليقول ان قيم الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
والعلمانيه في خطر امام تهديد الاسلام
الذي يعيش ازمه في العالم اجمع متناسيا
الازمات المركبه كافه التي تشهدها ميلاده
تصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي سبقتها وتلاتها
خطابات اكثر فجاجه تجاه المسلمين منها على
سبيل المثال للحصر تعهد احد مرشح الرئاسه
السابقين بحظر اطلاق اسم محمد على
المواليد في فرنسا وبتخليص البلاد من
الحجاب
هذه المواقف الصادمه قراها البعض كنتيجه
لبروز تيار اسلاميين متطرف نفذ سلسله
هجمات راح ضحيتها مدنيون ونجح اليمين
المتطرف في استغلالها من اجل تصعيد خطاب
الاسلام وفوبيا وحمل كثيرا من التيارات
السياسيه على اللحاق بركبه في المقابل
يعتبر البعض ان المسلمين الذين يناهز
عددهم سبعه ملايين نسمه في فرنسا لم
ينجحوا في التعبير عن انفسهم بالشكل
المطلوب على غرار ما فعل ابناء ديانات
اخرى وكان من مظاهر ذلك رفض شريحه كبيره
من المسلمين المشاركه الفعاله في
الانتخابات والحياه السياسيه وهو ما فاقم
اضعافها وتهميشها
قبل عشرين سنه عقدين كان يقال الاسلام
المسلمين المتطرفين الارهاب الاسلامي
الكذا ثم بدانا نتحول اكثر فاكثر الاسلام
السياسي ثم بدانا نتحول يعني هذا يؤكد ان
المستهدف الاساسي كان كان الثقافه
الاسلاميه او الدين الاسلامي الانتماء
لهذا الدين الاسلامي انت مهتم بالاسلام
السياسي كتبت عنه ارى عده كتب اسلام
السياسي صوت الجنوب نحو فهم الاسلام
السياسي
الان هناك عمل اوروبي فرنسي منظم الاسلام
السياسي هل هو مقصود فيه فقط الناشطون
السياسيون المسلمون ولا المجتمع المسلم
بشكل عام حاول مشكل المشكله لان
وصف مواطن فرنسيسه من اخوانه مسلمين
ادى الى وصف المواطن الذي
يريد ان يشارك في المقاس السياسي فقط فقط
بين قوسين التشدد الاسلامي موجود موجود
ولم نشير الى الضربات الارهابيه في فرنسا
في سنه 2015 وهذا هذه مرحله تاريخيه لا شك
في ذلك ان
اذا التشدد في خطاب السياسي
بدا مع هذه الضربات في 2015 وتلعب دور ليس
من الممكن ان نتجاهل هذا ولكن حاليا
الذي ينتمي الى الاخوان المسلمين ترفضون
المسلمين كمؤسسه تاريخيه ليست لهم وجود
حقيقه في فرنسا ضعيفه مسكين قدرتهم
لتاثير على الاعلان لا اله قليله جدا جدا
جدا بينما
كتب تنشر يوميا او شهريا تقول النار
الاخوان المسلمين على هام السيطره
المؤسسات الاوروبيه فرد خلافه اسلاميه
وهذا كلام فاضي وانا اعرف من الداخل هنا
يطلبون مني
الرسميه الحكوميه الفرنسيه
العلمي لكن البعد هنا كمواط ناشد سياسي
احيانا اقبل دعوات من الجمعيات التي تحاول
دفع حقوق الاخوان المسلمين في مصر مثلا
وانا اقول لك لما لما ينظمون
مناسبه في بروسل الجمهور الغرفه فاضيه ما
عندهم ما عندهم تاثير قوي فالكلام الذي
يقول ان هناك تحديد من اخواني المسلمين
على الحكومه او المجتمع الفرنسي فاضي
مرتبطه تعرف اشكالياتي لفهم الاسلام
السياسي انا قلت انا الاسلام السياسي
المرحله الثالثه في حركه تاريخيه استقلال
بلدان المنطقه بعض بعض
فتره الاستعمار انا قلت انا الصفحه الاولى
كانت السياسيه انتهت مع الاستقلالات
الصفحه الثانيه كانت اقتصاديه تعميم قناه
السويس
اعاده السيطره على النفط في الجزائر
وصفت الصفحه التاريخيه الثالثه للتاريخ
الاستقلال عن بعض الاستعمار كانها تاريخ
الاسلام السياسي
اعاده ارتباط
مصطلحات الدين
مصطلح حتى الدين كانه كانها مصطلحات
الثقافه المحليه التخلص من تدخل الثقافات
الغربيه في لغه الختام ما طبيعه العمل
المنظم والموجه لحركات الاسلام السياسي او
ممثل الاسلام السياسي في فرنسا اليوم
العمل من الحكومه لاستهداف هذه الجهات او
الافراد
الحكومه حلا البنيه
الجمعيه كل مؤسسات المسلمين الناشئين حتى
ولو في الدفاع
حقوق المواطنين للمسلمين اسوا ما وهنا
كتبت مقال تجده في
كل اللغات انا قلت ان الدوله الفرنسيه
غادرت فتره دوله القانون لما قام بالغاء
بحل جمعيات كانت تسميه
التحالف ضد اللسان في فرنسا والناس ما
كانوا تنتمي الى اي تيار سياسي كانوا
مواطنين مسلمين ناشيتين لمعالجه التوتر
بين الحكومه والمسلمين فهذا ما تفعل
الحكومه بين قوسين اسمح لي اضيف عامل مهم
ان الخطاب الاسلام فوبي لقوا حلفاء خارج
فرنسا خارج فرنسا اولا تتذكر ربما تسريح
جنرال شارون في 2000
واحد بعد احداث نيويورك مباشره قال شارون
عندكم بن لادن
عندنا ليس حماس ليس حركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه عندنا ياسر عرفات فما هو خلفيه
مثل هذا الخطاب
نركز على الانتماء العدتي او الديني من
المنافس او من المعارض اوكي في سنه 2019
زارت باريس
للعدد من شخصيات
من هذه المنطقه من العالم من الخليج
او طبعا مصر عبد الفتاح السيسي مثلا كان
لهم خطاب واحد
طلبوا من الحكومه الفرنسيه
المقافحه ديد ليس الارهاب ليس
السلفيين الجهاديين قالوا لابد
نساعدكم ان شاء الله لمكافحه الاسلام
السياسي
كانت عمليه شهيره كانت بالتعاون ايضا مع
اجهزه امنيه مصريه
كيف تعرف الدوله الفرنسيه الاسلام السياسي
يعني يبدو انه لا يوجد تعريف صلب انه
تعريف سائل يتجاوز في كل مره اليوم
النسخه الاخيره يعني خلينا نقول اخر نسخ
تعريف الاسلام السياسي في الدوله الفرنسيه
ما هي
قلت اعتقد ان
قبل كل شيء اعتقد ان النقاش في هذا
الموضوع غير
المستوى العقلاني لما نشير الى الاسلام او
المسلمين حاليا في فرنسا
نشارك في تنافس في
سباق في استقطاب اليمين المتشدد ما في
عقلانيه ما في موضوعيه
[موسيقى]
ما اريد ان اركز عليه لكن
خلال شهرين الى هدف شخصيا حمله اعلاميه
واسعه طبعا كفرنسي تتفهم لا فرنسي الذي
ينتقد من ينتقد المسلمين اذا تنتقد
مسؤلي
تسريحات اسلاموفوبيه شو يقولون يقولون انا
وجدت العباره باللغه العربيه باللغه
الفرنسيه يقولون شيء صعب الترجمه
يقولون باللغه الفرنسيه ان انا اربط حدث
على ذحري من اريد ان القتلى المسلمين
تقتلها تقتله او تقتلها باللغه العربيه
ابيح بدمه
او تبيع دماء المسؤولين تبيع اول ما تنتقد
شخص اسلاموفو للغايه ويرد هو شريك من
الذين قتلوا ذبحوا الاستاذ سمير مثلا من
المتشددين الاسلاميين
فيمنعونك
المشاركه في النقاش على شرط بالذرعه ان
انت
تغذي
التشدد الاسلامي وانت شريك من سوف
يقتلهم فرنسا الثوره فرنسا اعلان العالمي
لحقوق الانسان فرنسا الديمقراطيه الى اين
الى اين تذهب في ظل هذه يعني بفضل ما يجري
الان ما الاسف فرنسا
[موسيقى]
في الماضي اذا هذه الظاهره
كانت موجود داخل المجتمع الفرنسي على هامش
على وسط يمين على الان المشكله ان
اذا ابيه ظاهره حكوميه المشكل
وزير الداخليه يقول الاسلام السني طورها
ايضا الاسلام وحددوا السنه الاغلبيه وان
لماذا اخطر السنه
مشكل فرنسا
في ما يخص علاقاتها مع الجيران والاغلبيه
تخاف من الاغلبيه لما تصل الى السوريات
تركز على الاقل المسيحيه لما تصل الى بلد
عربي تركز على البربر لما امام جمهور من
الذكور تركز
انا من انتقل الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه مع
الاسف
يحدد الدبلوماسيات فرنسا
العدو الاسلامي بعمليه تحرير المراه
المسلمه هذا من اساليب فانها اعتقد ان
فرنسا حاليا يعني في لمن يحلل تصريحات
ضخمه
ضد الارهاب السني انا اعتقد اننا ينظر الى
السني كانهم يمثلون الاكثريه
والشيعه الاقليه طيب لم تحمل الفرق لم
تحمل المسلمين
الناشطين منهم المفكرين منهم المتشددين
منهم الكل يعني لم تحملهم اي جزء من
المسؤوليات تجاه ما يجري الان في فرنسا
يعني كانهم بوراء من كل هذا ما هي مسؤوليه
في هذا الامر
تشدد حامش
الفاعلين العسكريين في العراق
وسوريا
تحمل مسؤوليه لان عنف
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه تنقسم الى بعدين
العنف ضد نظام بشاره طيب عمد سياسي لكن
عنف الدينيه في العراق
هذا المسلمين في فرنسا خليني برا لبرا
يعني في تفسيرات كثيره لهذا الامر لكن
اقصد المسلمين في فرنسا ما في حدود ما في
حدود طيب المسلم في فرنسا اقول اولا دور
الانقسامات الداخليه عند المسلمين خطيره
جدا المسلم الفرنسي كثير ما حتى الان ما
يتعامل مع البيئه السياسيه كانه مسلم
فرنسي يتعامل بالبيئه بالامور السياسيه
كانه مسلم جزائري
تركي فهذه الانقسامات خطره جدا على
المسلمين الفرنسيين ان يرفعون الصوت واحد
وان يتخلصون ان يتجاوزون فتره التاريخ
الانتماء لبلدان الاجداد هذا اذا من جانب
يعني يتحول الى مسلمين فرنسي
عدد من الزملاء خلال الفتره الاخيره قلت
لهم لماذا
تشاركون لماذا ترفعون صوتهم مثل اخر مهم
للغايه ناس ساكن في مدينه جنوب فرنسا يوجد
ضحيه تجد اغلبيه الناس من المسلمين
انتخبوا واحد من اليمين المتشدد لماذا لان
المسلمون ما يسوتون
عفوا المسلمون الفرنسيون ما يصوتون
لا يريدون التصوير لا يثقون ما يثقون
معهم وانا معهم غير انا اعتقد ان المشاركه
السياسيه تبدا بالتسويد اذا يسوتون
للمستوى البلديات يرفع يعني ثمن ثقلهم
في ملاحظه انه تاثير ما يجري خارجيا كبير
جدا على فرنسا في الداخل العلاقه مع الدول
الاسلاميه العربيه وغير العربيه حينما
كانت انظمه الاسترداد مستقر لها الامر في
العالم العربي كانت الامور هادئه داخل
داخل فرنسا واوروبا حينما نشات حركات او
اصبح حينما جاء الربيع العربي وظهر ظهرت
حركات الاسلام السياسي حينما ظهر النموذج
التركي المحسوب على الاسلام السياسي توترت
الامور بشكل اكبر في الداخل كيف يؤثر
الخارج على مجريات
داخل الفرنسي في العلاقه ما بين الدوله
والمسلمين
انا ذكرت جانب من هذا التعاون
الاقليمي ان
الحكام
المستبيدين في المنطقه
يشاركون في عمليه تجريم
الاخوان المسلم او المواطن المسلم الذي لو
طموحات سياسيه فهذا التنسيق خطير جدا
تنسيق بين بعض الانظمه
والحكام الاوروبيين ودوله اسرائيل وتعرف
ان الاتفاقات الاخيره
جعلت هذه الظاهره اوداح بكثير
وطبعا
الجانب الاخر ان كل ما ظهر الطموحات
بطابع اسلامي كلما توترت فرنسا اكثر
هذا من تقاليد فرنسا
منذ العداله والتنميه ونموذج علماني
ديمقراطي لماذا يستفز فرنسا نبعث لانقاذ
الجزائري في اوائل التسعينات
[موسيقى]
احيانا
نتبادل الاراء مع الزملاء العرب ونقول اول
ربيع العربي ربما كان في
مدينه مدينه هاما مدينه حماه في سوريا
واخرون يقولون نموذج الجزائري
طلب شعبي قالوا لي
انتخبوا اغلبيه في البرلمان الو كانوا
كانوا مستعد
وتدخل فرنسا وايدوا
نفس الرد الذي تقوم به بشر الاسد حاليا
الى قام الدموي فهدم الاسف يعني انا اقصد
الان يعني استمرارا للفكره بروفيسور فرنسا
تتراجع بشكل حقيقي في افريقيا في مالي في
الدول المستعمرات التقليديه لها فرنسا
سياسيا مصدره ومكروهه في الدول التي كانت
ايضا تحتلها في شمال افريقيا الجزائر
والمغرب وتونس وما الى ذلك فرنسا في حاله
صدام مع مع اردوغان وتركيا النموذج الذي
ينظر له بعض المسلمين على انه نموذج معبر
عن عن المسلمين
الحديثين اليوم في النظام السياسي الا
تفكر فرنسا في اعاده بوصلتها والتفكير
بطريقه اخرى نفهم في السابق كانت مستعمره
لهذه الدول وتريد مستبدين للحفاظ على
مصالحه لكن العالم يتغير اليوم والناس
والانسان بشكل عام يتطور ويتقدم الامن الا
تفكر فرنسا في اعاده التفكير في اعاده
هيكله سياس ات الخارجيه علاقتها مع
المسلمين
نحن ننتمي الى اقليه المفكرين الذين
يطلبون من الحكم الفرنسيا ان يفعل ذلك ان
يتغير ان يتقدم
هم غير راغبين ولا عاجزين
مع الاسف الحكومه الفرنسيه حاليا تعطي
الاولويه للمصالح
الانتخابويه ربما مقرون يعرف ان هذا اتجاه
خاطئ
الدبلوماسيه يكسبه في الصلاه لكن يعطي
الاولويه لاعاده الانتخاب للاستمرار في
السلطه
ولذلك انا كنت
متشائم فيما يخص قدره فرنسا لعلاج سياستها
في
يعني اناء عده احيانا انظر الى الضغوط
الدوليه على فرنسا
كجزء من المشهد
المفيد كالجوز من العلاج
يعني في منذ قرون لما يتعامل فرنسا مع بلد
عربي يقول نحن معكم على الشرط ان تدافع
حمايه الاقليات الدينيه
حمايه المسيحيين في مصر حمايه المسيحيين
في العراق وانا اسال للدول العرب والمسلمه
حاليا ان يقدموا لي الى فرنسا نفس الشرط
تريد ان تبيع لنا رفال نطلب منكم
حمايه الاقليه
لو افترضنا انك في موقع صناعه القرار في
في
في فرنسا برايك ما هي روشته اصلاح الموقف
السياسي الفرنسي تجاه المسلمين كمواطنين
وتجاه الاسلام كدين والدول الاسلاميه
خلينا نضع اولويات هناك نوع من الحاووس
حول
القضيه الاسلاميه في فرنسا لماذا هذه
وسيله بيد الاعلاميين للنفى المشاكل
الحقيقيه المشاكل الحقيقيه امام المجتمع
الفرنسي ليس اوجود بعض المسلمين في فرنسا
ليس خوف
تطور جمعيات الاخوان المسلمين لفرد خلافه
اسلاميه
المشاكل هي
الخروج من فتره الهيمنه التحدي للغرب
حاليا ان عاش فتره الحيمه على العالم فتره
الهيم السياسيه
الثقافيه اللغويه وعليه ان يعود الى مستوى
[موسيقى]
متواضعه يتواضع متواضع يقبل بوجودها لا
يستتيا اذا طريق صعب جدا لما نخرج من فتره
هيمنه الدور اصعب الدور للمهيمن
[موسيقى]
فعلى فرنسا ان تقبل فكره ان لا تهيمن على
العالم انتهت هذه الفتره
[موسيقى]
ان تركز على المشاكل الحقيقيه وهي مشاكل
اقتصاديه مشاكل ليس لها
علاقه مع الاخر الاسلامي اذا حنا كنا
حصرناها بالمسلمين في افريقيا ليس لها
علاقه بالاسلام لها علاقه بالاستعمار
كفكره ايضا تواجه تحديات وجوديه فرنسا في
هذه المساله هل هذا يثير الانتباه انه
المشكله فقط ليست المسلمين
فيما يخصوا بقيت افريقيا ليس شمال افريقيا
اسمحوا لي اضيف فكره
الذي يدلل ماب الموضوع ليس الدين
السيطره خروج من
اذا
احفاد
المستعمرين يرفع صوته وليس من المسلمين
ومن الافارقه
رد المجتمع الفرنسي نفس نفس الرادة يجرم
طالبات
مطالب
شعوب افريقيا ويقولون
يرقيه او مطالب عنصريه بينما يقول مطاليب
اصوليه او اسلاميه اذا
اسواق احفاد المستعمرين من المجتمعات
الاسلاميه
اذا اشكاليه واحده اشكاليه واحده ان نكتب
صفحه خروج من الهيمنه الاستعماريه
وتقديم وتقديم شكل جديد في الشكل الجديد
للدوله الفرنسيه والعلاقات مع مع
المستعمرين هل قفرنسا قادره على ذلك
النخبه اليوم الحاله الشعبويه حاله مخيفه
في فرنسا
الانتخاباويه كما وصفتها هي المؤثر هل
نتوقع قرارات استراتيجيه مثل هذه
لسياسيين
يتاثرون بالصندوق وبالناخب وباصوات اكثر
او اقل
بصراحه اقول لك هل القضيه اتركه للعارفين
كل معارف والماضي والحاضر
ومنذ 15 سنه الى من المتشائمين انا اقول
ان تزيين التين سنه
عفوا تنتظرنا صدامات بين المسلمين والدوله
الاوروبيه بشكل عام في فرنسا وغيرها
نتيجه هذا الاوضاع اترك هذه
الاطروحه للعارفين لكن طبعا طبعا يجيد
اشارات سلبيه حاليا في العلاقات بين فرنسا
والمسلمين اما في فرنسا او في الخارج كانك
بروفيسور نتيجه بقائك في العالم العربي
فتره طويله انت اول مره زرت القدس 64
زرتها كحاب صح كحاج مسيحي يعني
لكن يبدو ان ايضا تبنيت الموقف الاسلامي
العربي من الدوله الفرنسيه ومن الصراع
القائم بين الاوروبيين والمسلمين كلا
كلا اذا لست مع
المسلمين او مع في السياسيه معينه مع
العداله هنا مع
احترام الاخر
هنا مع فرنسا لكن
فرنسا الذي
كما لازم ان تكون كمان حزمه تاكل
لم لم نتحدث عن بس في ختام الحلقه عن
مسؤوليه ما يجري في العالم العربي على
الحاله في فرنسا يعني دول الاستبداد يبدو
انه قدرها
التاخر التراجع التخلف حتى حينما نهضت في
بعض الحالات في تونس راينا كيف اله الامور
في نهايه المطاف الا يبدو انه ايضا هذا
يحمل الطرف الاخر المرتبط بالاسلام كدين
اقصد المسلمين مسؤوليات تجاه هذه الازمه
مبدئيا اناء لا اقول انا
مسؤوليه الجانب الاسوا من ما يحدث في
العالم هو الغرب انا اقول المسؤوليه على
المهيمنين على الحكام
احيانا اسمع ليس للغرب قيم
فانا اقول ولهذا الحاكم العربي المسلم لو
قيم المشكل ليس القيم المشكل قدره كل مننا
لاحترام قيمنا لاحترام قيامنا الحاكم الذي
لا يستطيع ان يحترم قيامه
وفي نفس المشهد
والحاكم العربي المستبد لو قيم لكن ما
يحترمون
التحدي الحقيقي ليس ثقافه الغرب ثقافه
الاسلام لا التحدي الرئيسيه قدره كل كن من
الفائلين السياسيين لاحترام قيمهم
الاسلاموفوبيا ما مصيرها ما مستقبلها
برايك بتطور
بحده اكبر ام يمكن ضبط هذا الامر بمعالجات
ما
حاليا نحن في اتجاه صعب تؤدي الى ايام
اسوا ولكن
التاريخ
[موسيقى]
نعرف من التاريخ ان هذا الاتجاه الظهيره
حاليا ليست الاتجاه الوحيد
فنترك مسافه لشيء من التفاؤل
البروفيسور
الباحث الاكاديمي والمثقف والمفكر الفرنسي
العارف ببواطن الامور في العالم العربي
شكرا جزيلا لك ضيف المقابله في هذه الحلقه
شكرا لكم شكرا موصول لكم انتم مشاهدينا
الكرام على الطيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء
الله الاسبوع المقبل مع حلقه جديده من
المقابله في امان الله
شكرا
[موسيقى]